they thought they'd fled to safety
escaping troops in russian-controlled
territory
[Music]
we've come through floods and Rapid
currents but even amidst the hugs and
sheer relief there's the unmistakable
sound of War getting closer
home home home she keeps repeating but
their Joy is very short-lived
there's another attack much closer this
time it seems to be deliberately aimed
at this evacuation point and there's
Panic the rescued and The Rescuers are
forced to Run for Cover
Alex
Alex it's been an incoming call now and
all the evacuation operations have had
to scatter All The Rescuers factors
scatter and just even these people just
waiting all just headed for shelters and
buildings they don't want to leave even
the smallest behind many of these people
are already traumatized amongst them
those who are trying to help during this
huge emergency
body armor was hastily put on by eight
volunteers taken by surprise
foreign
but they're attacked again
[Applause]
even as they try to save their few
emergency supplies
there is still a lot of incoming and
it's getting closer we might have to
retreat certainly a lot of the rescue
workers the few that were here have
scattered wildly and said that's it for
today they're basically just packing up
now and they're still coming under
attack
on water it's worse
a relief effort rescuing the stranded
and vulnerable from a deliberate
flooding now being repeatedly targeted
it's hard to imagine it getting much
more frightening for these people
there's been incredible bravery with
these volunteers despite being under
Fire and now carrying injured still
pushing through and steering those most
in need to dry land and safety the
swollen danipro River and flood zone is
now being punctured by multiple attacks
earlier the Ukrainian leader traveled to
the emergency area dropping in on one of
the evacuation points he's urged global
leaders to respond more quickly
large-scale Aid efforts are needed here
he says hours later that same evacuation
point was bombed
we were given this footage by a soldier
rushing another injured civilian to
safety
but still the attacks continued forcing
the frail and elderly to shelter but not
crushing their determined spirit
they bombed our apartment before New
Year she tells us we've been through it
all I'm not afraid of anything anymore
and amid the attacks in her son multiple
reports of a Ukrainian push on two
fighting fronts in the south and east
sudden ramped up activity in the midst
of a flood's emergency Alex Crawford Sky
News hairson in southern Ukraine